por su geografía jugará es una ciudad
vulnerable está situada en la parte baja
de varias Colinas Jordania en las que se
han construido colonias judías fue aquí
donde en 2009 abdulado de cumplió su
sueño tener un pequeño parque de
atracciones en la Ladera cada día
recibía hasta 1000 visitantes pero desde
el verano pasado cuando comenzaron los
reiterados ataques de los colonos
israelíes en su propiedad nadie se
atreve a venir se acabó ahora la gente
tiene miedo de venir
nadie quiere arriesgar su vida por estar
aquí porque además no se sabe cuándo
vendrán a atacar
perdió todo lo que había invertido estas
imágenes fueron captadas por sus cámaras
de seguridad que graban el
estacionamiento del parque son de
diciembre pasado unos jóvenes colonos
arrojan piedras a la entrada del parque
y queman unos vehículos
los ataques de los colonos empezaron
mucho antes del acto de venganza que
tuvo lugar en febrero pasado cuando
varias decenas de colonos entraron a
jugar a
quemaron vehículos y viviendas para
vengar la muerte de dos jóvenes
israelíes asesinados por un palestino
últimamente es como si se hubieran
vuelto Locos desde agosto hasta ahora
los ataques son frecuentes ya no sé qué
hacer honestamente no sé qué hacer
están atacando mis dos empresas el
parque
y mis camiones de la compañía de
transporte
son todas mis fuentes de ingresos atacan
todo lo que tengo y no dejan nada
Incluso quemaron la casa que Estoy
construyendo
extenderse por el norte de cisjordania
sanablus es una de las prioridades de
los colonos la zona es una de las más
violentas de los territorios palestinos
el grupo de colonos llamado juventud de
las colinas es uno de los más
extremistas está integrado por jóvenes
entre 15 y 25 años que suelen ser los
responsables de los ataques contra los
palestinos de manera excepcional
aceptaron la presencia de nuestra cámara
un campamento ilegal instalado unos días
antes este grupo de la juventud de las
colinas acaba de ser desmantelado por la
policía israelí
fue así llegaron aquí a la colina se
llevaron la tienda de campaña las
estacas nos quitaron todos los colchones
y las mantas hace un año y medio también
estábamos aquí y nos desalojaron varias
veces han convertido esto en una zona
militar la colina cayó en sus manos pero
ahora hemos regresado
cuando las fuerzas de seguridad se
marchan ellos reconstruyen su campamento
en medio de las ciudades palestinas
en la camiseta de este Joven se lee no
hay paz con los terroristas
tienen las piedras listas por si un
palestino se acerca pero también se
consideran víctimas
no hay que tenerles miedo tratan de
sacarnos de la Colina con sus atentados
pero no podemos ceder
hacen un rezo para estos adolescentes
fanáticos las colinas son un derecho
divino y un campo de batalla
cada colina es un territorio del país de
Israel claro tenemos que hacer cálculos
para saber dónde instalarnos pero cada
colina es nuestra tierra en la época de
Joshua las colinas también estaban en
guerra
hay que conquistarlas todas aquí nuestra
arma es la construcción con ella
conquistaremos estos lugares el nuevo
gobierno de Israel les parece demasiado
blando A pesar de que es el más
derechista que ha habido en la historia
del país pero la presencia de ministros
que respalden a los colonos les da
impulso regreso a jugará la ciudad de
cisjordania donde los colonos llevaron a
cabo su revancha se está construyendo
una Circunvalación que les permita
llegar a sus colonias sin cruzar la
ciudad en la carretera actual colonos y
soldados israelíes son constantemente
atacados por militantes palestinos
armados nos encontramos con estos
jóvenes militantes palestinos en uno de
sus bastiones el campamento de
refugiados de balata en la blusa sus
miembros que no alcanzan los 20 años
están a cargo de fabricar explosivos
artesanales
en sus dispositivos están impresas las
fotos de los militantes que murieron en
los anteriores ataques israelíes uno de
los jefes se batallón de 22 años aceptó
hablar sobre los últimos ataques contra
los puestos de control israelíes y los
colonos para él El único objetivo de los
ataques es generar un efecto disuasorio
el resultado de los últimos ataques
palestinos en cisjordania es que los
colonos han empezado a reducir sus
ataques contra nosotros
Seguiremos haciendo el mismo tipo de
operaciones contra ellos la consecuencia
es que el ejército hace más operaciones
aquí y hay más puestos de control
alrededor de la ciudad es cierto el
ejército lleva a cabo las operaciones
una mujer los colonos han reducido la
frecuencia de sus ataques
para él la ausencia de perspectiva
política solo le deja un camino a los
jóvenes el campamento el de una guerra
territorial que inexorablemente los
conduce a la cárcel o la muerte